we the people do you know the rest of  that verse turns out dozens upon dozens  of local elementary school students do  they recently received the great  american pride award and were recognized  at today's las vegas city council  meeting that distinction is given to  students who know how to recite the  preamble to the constitution the  gettysburg address name all the  presidents states and capital sing the  national anthem and write the pledge of  allegiance  for the students that i have i hope that  they can reflect back on this experience  and realize that they can persevere and  with determination they can do anything  that they set their minds to in the  future  this is quite an accomplishment ccsd  students get all year to tackle that  challenge before graduating onto middle  school